Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier- Don't laugh when I'm doing my intro man...
My name is Markipler, and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot, the original game
I'm going back on the high road picking up exactly where I left off.
Now, I'm thinking if I don't be an idiot about things, and I calmed down and I just take my flip-dicking time,
I'll be just fine. So yeah, yes, I just I just gotta use my brain!
I've just got to think about what I'm- What I'm doing in the- Dude. Don't- you're gonna make me faster though
I don't like that you make me faster. Ugh, I don't like how that handles now!
Ahkay, you're dead. How long does this last and why and also, what?
Okay, oh, God damn it! Can I make that jump though? Yeah? No, I can't! God dammit. It's fine.
Everything's cool. 'Cause I'm gonna get through this. That's how I do. That's what I do.
That's how I do things in this neighborhood.
Yeah, yeah, okay right on- IN THE MIDDLE?!
Threading the needle?!
Really, that's what you're gonna do to me? On my return back into this, when I'm calm and collected, which I am. Nobody say I'm otherwise.
Yeah, the trick to these turtles-
(absolute silence)
AGHH. The trick to these turtles is just:
Patience.
Noooo!
There we go. That's barely making it though. That's such a tight margin of error.
Ugh.
Like this one is just- Okay. I'm gonna do what I was doing before. Which is just watching my shadows.
Even though I see myself sliding off. BOINK.
Oh my God, I'm not gonna go on the ropes! That's cheating!
God, it's cheating!
Ugh, they built this to be done this way, and my God I'm gonna do it- you son of a bitch.
I don't know why. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, woah.
AAAAUUGGH
Come on!
That's fucking impossible!
Oh wow, okay. Yeah, sure let's do that.
Well, that was fast.
Mask: GAME OVER
Okay. We got this.
It's easy. It's easy. It's easy! It is easy.
It's easy. Oh, it's easy. I am holding jump to bounce higher off a flip turtle. I am.
Urrrgh.
You know, that's the thing about this game, like, I guess it's different in a good way like,
Everyone knows what to do, right? Everyone knows,
WHAT you need to do.
It's just doing it and executing it. That's the only thing. So you know there's no real trick
that's like: "Oh, jump on the rope
Oh, what're you doing, you idiot?" like you know it's not really that, because I could but also the grubs finicky, too
It's like we all know what needs to be done here, so let's just all band together, whoa
We're such a close call there Bubba
Why?
Let's go on the rope for this - only this segment because otherwise it would be cheating right? I'm just gonna
NO, WHY DIDN'T YOU JUMP OFF OF HIM?!
I was right there, there was a checkpoint right in front of my fricking face
No, why would you slide? I'm only I'm literally pressing the directional. Oh, I forgot. God damnit
I was just oh, I wanted to stop and talk to you guys, but I forgot that I'm on a red board
NO!
Oh my God! Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God! Oh my God!
Yay, yay, yay, yeah yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!  Got a lot of fucking *mumbling*...
That was a better bounce. I don't know why suddenly I'm getting a better bounce out of this, but let me just -
OUAAAAGGGHH!
Mask: Game over
Oh Danny boy the pipes the pipes are calling
Don't want that. I hate this I hate this why would I want this now? Oh?
You messed me up you messed me up with that. Oh
Oh my God
I'm losing it. I'm losing it. I'm losing- OH MY GOD
Why is this so hard now? why is this the thing I can't do?! this is simp- OH MY GOD
This is simple. This is so simple. Why is this the thing now?
Okay, there. fine there we go I just got to concentrate
Okay, you wait wait. Okay. You go all the way to the very edge
*grunts*
Yes
I did that I did that. I did that okay ignore you, ha, he ignore you, go yes!
YES
Huh, that was the first one. Oh my God. It's nothing, but it's nothing but turtle jumps
Why God, no that was bad one
AHHHH
Well there you go, then. I had a saving grace, and then I lost it. Well. I bumped that too soon
Now I'm boned gonna jump on the rope because I'm a cheating bastard
Cheating bastard. Oh that felt good. NO WHAT THE HELL
What did you do?!
What did you even do?!
I literally only hit up. It's the only button. I press in this goddamn game
Fine, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. I'm fine
We're all fine here
Everyone's fine
That pigs fine
Fell off into the abyss got speared up its own butthole by spike. That's fine
As I said
All fine
That time I went intentionally diagonal
Okay, don't go yet you go all the way to the edge good. Cuz I won't learn anything
You won't let me no that was bad one
Okay, that was a good bounce
That was a less good bounce
That was good one, okay getting it oh
Sweet delicious Checkpoint of the Gods alright you stay there, all right
ohohoho
OH COME ON NO!
OH FUCK YOU MAN
God, I'm not gonna quit. Oh
I'm not quitting. I'm not I'm not I'm smiling. I'm smiling that means I'm happy right? If you smile, you're happier, right?
That's what happens when you smile, you just send happiness blood gene through your blood and get happy
No, why no?
*weird markiplier noises*
Okay
Oh My God, oh my God, are you kidding me?
God, why can't I do this anymore?
It's the very beginning. It's the very beginning. It's a sequence
It's such a simple sequence forward back foward jump jump forward. That's all it is that's how you do those jumps
You just a either fit forward first or jump first, and you go shorter or farther, and it's super easy
Why am I not doing it? Oh
Frick oh God
Mask: GAME OVER
Say can you see
By the Dawn's early light. I'm gonna nail my balls to the wall
I'm gonna cut off my nipples and glue them
to my toes
One shot baby, one shot baby one punch Mark one punch Mark one punch bandicoot I'm gonna punch a bandicoot uh
No, that was bad. I could tell I felt that in my butt
Nope, nose.
Oh Yeah, that's good
Go and then a little bit, but not oh, yeah there we go. Oh mmm yeah mmm
Got this on. Nope that was too.. Gonna take the rope Gonna take the rope cause Oohhh
*more grunting*
Oh yeah. Oh these are oh these are good turts.
Oh these are good turtles with soft underbellies. Oh no. Oh no. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no
Can't do this with directional pad. Why am I doing it with
No how are you there? I don't know I don't care here we go nooooooo
I'm gonna play with my controller behind my head because I can I'm gonna fuckin do it. You know, what fuck you
I'm going on the rope
Don't do that. You get over there. I'm gonna jump on you now with the goddamn control. Oh no I'm not gonna make it
Ohhhh it physically hurts me in my grundle it physically hurts me. Oh, I hurts me. I'm gonna make it
Cuz I'm a winner baby don't you believe how much of a winner I am? Ohh feel my winning throbbing wins
I'm going back to that. I'm going back to the other one. Nope. You know what this was a mistake. I can tell
Eh no get on his bell nooo why would you slide off?
My shadow was right there oh my shadow was on it, it slid off
Yes, I would like to retry I'd like to go on Mr.. Bones Wild Ride one last time
Nope that wouldn't have made it it. This is gonna make it
What in the world?
Why does sometimes I'd bounce out of a turtle and it does a short jump it does it on purpose
It's like is that Markiplier. I'm not a fan of him. No no. I'm more of a Pewdiepie kind of guy
I'm more of a Logan Paul. I'm a member of the Lo gang I wouldn't have anything to do with this oh
Mask: game over, Mark:Fuck.This is the one. I just concentrate stop being such a prick
not
It's fine. That's fine. It's fine. Everything's fine. I'm just gonna go
Yeah, oh my God. Oh my God. What happened? What happened? Oh. What happened? What happened? What happened?
What happened? What happened to you?
Markiplier you've changed
Fame went to your head fuck
Oh, I'm desperate oh fuck off
Fuck it noooo
All right, I don't wanna game over again. I don't wanna do it
I'm not even halfway through this level which is the worst part oh
No, God damn it fuck off.
Oh I'm trying to fucking concentrate. I really am I'm I've never been so try hard in my life
Not even own like twenty twenty modes have I been this try hard, but oh my God you are fucking kidding me
I'm gonna do this I'm doing it legitimately because one it's a point of pride at this point
Why are you so difficult?
It scares the piss out of me every goddamn time oh
No, oh my God. I was right there
Haha why? I just oh fuck off.
Ohhhhhh fuck
nope
Ughhh
Okay
Yeah, there we go. Okay, checkpoint life this girl this thing that okay got it.
Oh yeah
That's the good stuff. Oh. Yeah, this is the good stuff this I can handle. Pigs? I can handle all day
I could take care of pigs all day
Okay give it to me, give it to me I've earned this I've nooo I thought I was gonna thread the needle
But I didn't so I guess that's good
Oh my God. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god umm. I see that up there
Oh, well, I was gonna go get it
But I can't now so I guess I'll just dance with the pants off got it anyway. Oh boy is there something out there?
Oh my God there was but now I can't get it. Yes, I can
Oh fuck off what why did you are I? Okay. You wait.
I'm gonna wait for you, and then you tell me when you're ready
Ughhh
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no go back go back. Oh my god. Oh my God
Nope, nah, I didn't feel that one. Goooooooo. Why am I over there?
Why was I over there? Someone expl
Made it
I hate this so much I hate this so much it is it is everything I abhor oh?
How?
I guess I'll come back for those
No, that's the opposite of good
Okay that's alright then you can afford that because you can do that as many times as you need
But I'm not going to get away from getting those goddamn bonuses at least they didn't put this bonus platform off the ledge
Because that would be real shitty of them
Okay, straight down got it
Okay, come on. Someone give me a life one of you better have a life in you
Okay, well, there's the lives okay
got two lives
That's good, and I'll probably get another bonus from the apples. That's good
I'm almost there.This is got to be the
last stretch
Just these turtles. It's fine. I got this these turtles aren't even that hard. Oh, I see what you're doing here
No, oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh
Don't go sideways what in the hell?
Your shadow was there. Oh my God one last piece of shit bullshit before. I'm off
You just had to send me off in style right? You just had to do it or else
You would have been so mad at yourself
Because why not oh my God Imma go home?
Yes
Yes, yes, yes, I'm shoving my face to you
Yes, I did it. There we go. I'm happy
Everyone's happy everyone's happy
I did it
Great, so thank you everybody so much for watching I'm gonna keep going on this one like I said gotta beat the game
In one sitting maybe not but either way...
Thank you, everybody who believed in me. Thank you everybody who didn't believe in me. I heard your cheers all the way
from the future
which it was
When you saw it, but I think all of you if you remember at 6:14 p.m.
July
7th
July 7 6:14 p.m.. If you felt a disturbance in the force at that point on that day. Oh that was me
That was me. Oh that was me okay. So anyway
Thank you, everybody again, and as always. I will see you in the next video. Bye bye!
WHAT?????